well Finch My Sword I don't tell anyone  I mixed a couple of things but they're  new they're gone and then other pins  what have you done with them and I went  oh but they I got something at the end  yeah not my knife I want my knife  still want my knife gifted thing we we  did not we we know nothing we're not no  no  I wish though  I would have taken like a chalice we  have these these marbles in the small  Council chamber which we put on like a  donut to signif to signify that you know  we're on record here and I had a really  nice one it was really waiting it's they  would have taken that because it's fun  to just like you know whip them at each  other